to date a case has not been documented
in which the corona virus has been
transmitted to humans from surfaces
contaminated with the virus still the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention recommends that frequently
touch surfaces in your house
should be routinely cleaned and
disinfected to lessen the chances of
transmission but how exactly should you
just infect all the surfaces in your
home first off be sure to read the
labels of your products to ensure
correct usage and safety use EPA
approved disinfectants and it's best to
use disposable gloves if using reusable
gloves be sure to use them only while
cleaning and disinfecting for the corona
virus always wash your hands immediately
after taking the gloves off focus on
cleaning and disinfecting the most
frequently touch surfaces in your home
think tables doorknobs handles light
switches desks toilets faucets sinks and
electronics when it comes to electronics
research suggests that the virus can
last a long time on these types of
surfaces for non-porous surfaces like a
keyboard or a phone research from the
National Institutes of Health
CDC Princeton University and UCLA says
that the virus could live on them for
two to three days
the CDC suggests removing any visible
contaminant if possible to disinfect you
should follow the instructions from the
manufacturer Apple recently updated its
guidelines for disinfecting its products
to clean your iPhone you can clean it
with a damp lens cloth and then gently
wipe it with a Clorox disinfecting wipe
while avoiding getting any moisture in
any of the openings you can also use the
wipes on your other Apple products such
as your laptop if your electronics
manufacturer doesn't provide
disinfecting instructions the CDC
suggests using alcohol wipes or sprays
with at least 70% alcohol for
touchscreens and all services should be
thoroughly dried to avoid any pools of
liquid forming
for hard surfaces the corona virus
appears to last the longest on plastic
and stainless steel about two to three
days if your surfaces are dirty be sure
to first clean them with a detergent or
soap and water before you disinfect you
can then use an EPA approved
disinfectant on the surface diluted
household bleach solutions are an option
but make sure to follow the
manufacturer's instructions for
application make sure it's not expired
and never mix household bleach with
ammonia or any other cleanser make sure
to open a window so you have plenty of
ventilation while and after applying the
bleach to make a bleach solution mix
five tablespoons of bleach per gallon of
water or four teaspoons of bleach per
quart of water for soft surfaces such as
carpeted floor rugs and drapes first
wipe off any dirt or contaminants you
can see then use an approved cleaner at
while following the cleaners
manufacturer instructions if possible
put the items in the laundry according
to their manufacturer instructions using
a warmest appropriate water setting be
sure to dry thoroughly
dirty laundry from an ill person can be
washed with other people's items but if
you need to handle laundry for someone
who's sick use disposable gloves or
gloves that are dedicated to cleaning
and disinfecting for the coronavirus do
not shake dirty laundry this will
minimize the possibility of dispersing
the virus through the air use the
warmest water setting appropriate for
your items and make sure they're dried
thoroughly
also be sure to clean and disinfect your
hamper if possible you should use liners
that are disposable or washable and
finally clean your hands immediately
after using the gloves if you don't use
gloves be sure to just wash your hands
immediately after handling the laundry
make sure you follow the CDC's
additional home care guidelines on its
website when caring for a sick person if
possible allow a person to clean and
disinfect their own bedroom and bathroom
and just a reminder cleaning surfaces is
not a substitute for washing hands
experts say washing your hands with soap
and water and avoiding touching your
face are still the best ways to avoid
contracting the virus so at the very
least keep washing those hands
[Music]
you